[Musica]
ci sono tante battute che circolano su
gli antropologi c'è chi dice che mentre
gli psicologi si occupano del io i
filosofi si occupano di dio quindi cose
importanti
gli antropologi si occupano dello zio
oppure ancora che i sociologi fanno i
sociologi perché hanno problemi con gli
altri gli psicologi fanno gli psicologi
perché hanno problemi con se stessi gli
antropologi e fanno gli antropologi
perché hanno problemi sia con se stessi
sia con gli altri
ed ecco una classica reazione all'arrivo
degli antropologi sul campo vediamo se
la tecnologia ci aiuta
ecco fuggi fuggi c'è un ulteriore
pregiudizio questa volta interno alla
disciplina rispetto a quelli antropologi
cosiddetti d'acqua dolce cioè che fanno
ricerca vicino a casa antropologia
domestica viene anche chiamata
ecco non solo io sono un'antropologa io
sono un'antropologa d'acqua dolce una
cioè che fa ricerca sotto casa anziché i
luoghi lontani da una parte perché ho
bisogno di sentirmi a casa in ogni luogo
e per questo ci vuole tempo per
conoscere le persone per fare in modo
che i luoghi diventino parte della mia
vita e del mio panorama ma non solo
e anche perché il tipo di antropologia
che ho scelto è un tipo di
sperimentazione che ha applicato e
pubblico implicato nell accompagnamento
dei percorsi di cambiamento che hanno
quindi tempi lunghi e spesso esiti
incerti ma oggi per parlarvi di bellezza
e di come si può costruirla insieme
voglio provare a fare quello che gli
antropologi chiamano il giro lungo cioè
andare lontano confrontarsi con la
diversità con l'altro e l'altrove per
poi tornare a casa più consapevoli di
ciò che siamo e di ciò che ci circonda
per il nostro giro lungo voglio portarvi
in amazzonia tra il kayapo del mato
grosso
ed ecco i nostri caja poi torniamo
l'immagine precedente perché volevo
ancora farvi vedere il fiume volevo
farvi vedere la foresta che non sono
solamente elementi essenziali per la
sussistenza materiale del cai up ma sono
i luoghi in cui si svolgono importanti
riti che danno forma l'identità indigena
e che sono ritenuti fondamentali per la
vita stessa del gruppo
ecco la tartaruga perché la tartaruga
perché in occasione della cerimonia
dell'attribuzione del nome bellissimo a
un bambino del villaggio il nome
bellissimo è un segno importante di
distinzione di prestigio sociale
i cacciatori kayapo sono impegnati in
una lunga battuta di caccia rituale tra
la foresta e il fiume per catturare le
tartarughe che daranno di che nutrirsi a
tutto il villaggio durante la festa e la
famiglia del bambino prescelto per avere
il nome bellissimo riceve le tartarughe
in dono dai cacciatori e li
ridistribuisce a tutto il villaggio
l'occasione della festa del nome
bellissimo è una delle più importanti
poiché la bellezza è uno dei valori più
alti tra i kayapo il momento in cui si
esprime nel modo più completo il valore
della bellezza è proprio quello che
vedete quello della danza della danza
rituale attraverso la danza che vede
muoversi all'unisono i corpi dipinti
adornati per la cerimonia all'interno di
un unico corpo sociale si raggiunge la
massima espressione della bellezza fare
insieme
danzare insieme rende visibile a tutti
questa bellezza che supera nel tempo
straordinario del tempo rituale le
rigide suddivisioni di genere e di
generazioni che caratterizzano la vita
dei kayapo oggi quei rituali la
sopravvivenza materiale e culturale di
quei popoli sono minacciati dalle grandi
opere che stanno riducendo la foresta e
deviando il corso dei fiumi
questa è la grande diga di belo mondo
senza la foresta però senza il fiume
senza le tartarughe il rito del nome
bellissimo non può essere celebrato e la
vita stessa del kayapo è messa a rischio
ma il caja paul non si arrendono sono
guerrieri valorosi e combattono ormai
insieme a migliaia e migliaia di persone
in tutto il mondo che hanno capito il
valore dell'equilibrio che dava vita a
quella bellezza
e allora che cosa ho imparato in questo
giro lungo tra i kayapò dell'amazzonia
personalmente ho imparato che la
bellezza non è un dato ma è un processo
la bellezza si fa e si costruisce
insieme ho toccato letteralmente con
mano questo lo dipinto insieme ad altri
lavorando con colleghi designer studenti
universitari persone senza dimora o con
dimora operatori sociali cittadini
ristrutturando e ripensando insieme gli
spazi di accoglienza per chi si trova in
una condizione di profondo disagio
strada facendo tra milano torino verona
agrigento superando un po come i kayapo
nella foresta prove e riti di
iniziazione abbiamo imparato che non
basta progettare consegnare luoghi alle
persone per quanto accoglienti questo è
un dormitorio pubblico rischiando però
di farle sentire estranee in soggezione
o addirittura respinte da ambienti che
non riconoscono come propri
perché la bellezza si costruisce insieme
ed è da quel gesto collettivo di cura
che si crea il vero benessere che
diventa quindi duraturo è davvero
condiviso sperimentando insieme
lavorando insieme a tante persone di età
provenienza estrazione sociale
appartenenza culturale competenze
diverse
abbiamo affinato nel tempo l'idea che il
bello cura e allora dal 2014 a torino
abbiamo aperto un laboratorio permanente
il laboratorio costruire bellezza si
trova in via ghedini 6 a torino
quartiere di barriera di milano è
diventato permanente anche grazie alla
collaborazione con il comune di torino e
con le cooperative sociali che
gestiscono i servizi di accoglienza
urna e notturna per le persone senza
dimora
abbiamo pensato a costruire bellezza non
come a un evento ma come un laboratorio
permanente in cui sperimentare giorno
per giorno quotidianamente la bellezza
facendo insieme perché la questione del
tempo è fondamentale la fiducia la
collaborazione quella che è chi è in
venga chiama la comunità di pratica la
vedete qui si forma soltanto con il
tempo e basandosi sul rispetto e sul
riconoscimento reciproco
l'idea è semplice persone enti
istituzioni e associazioni ciascuno
contribuisce con ciò che di meglio ha da
dare e da condividere il sapere che
scoperta abbiamo fatto
beh scoprire l'acqua calda ma intanto io
sono un antropologa d'acqua dolce 15 st
tanto semplice da sembrare ovvia che più
le persone ma anche le istituzioni si
sentono riconosciute e valorizzate più
si aprono e mettono a disposizione ciò
che sono e ciò che hanno anche
all'interno di un circuito del dono
proprio quello che lega i cacciatori
kayapo che donano le tartarughe alla
famiglia del bambino che riceverà il
nome bellissimo anche in costruire
bellezza come vedete ci sono tanti
momenti di festa di danza pranzi e cene
non vediamo l'ora di essere di nuovo
così tanti dopo la pausa covip con
tantissime persone invitate
ma è soprattutto nella condivisione
quotidiana e non negli elementi
eccezionali sono i piccoli gesti che
abbiamo sperimentato e che ci hanno dato
e fatto vedere la vera bellezza gesti
semplici come questo come fare la spesa
al mercato del quartiere cucinare
insieme ridare vita e forma degli
oggetti ormai in disuso oppure imprese
più impegnative come aiutare un artista
internazionale a creare una grande opera
d'arte allestire una mostra costruire
immobili per una casa oppure giocattoli
per i bambini la bellezza dei corpi dei
kayapò che danzano ve ne ricordate ve li
ho fatti vedere poco fa beh non è così
dissimile dalla bellezza di queste mani
di questi corpi che fanno insieme
nei progetti che prendono vita dalla
collaborazione tra tante persone così
diverse che però hanno un grande valore
un grande vantaggio hanno deciso di
superare facendo insieme differenze e
quindi diffidenze reciproche e come tra
i kayapo durante le danze rituali anche
in costruire bellezza i ruoli sociali
vengono superati facendo insieme
ciascuno ha un proprio ruolo ma legato a
ciò che è e ciò che sa fare e non per
l'etichetta che la società gli ha
attribuito quindi la bellezza sta anche
nella sensazione di tregua di
sospensione del giudizio a un po di pace
non c'è competizione non c'è ansia da
prestazione o tempi da rispettare se non
per la preparazione del pranzo quello sì
fare insieme significa co progettare
cooperare ma significa anche
responsabilità cura gli uni verso gli
altri
riconoscere a ciascuno è qui il nostro
tema il proprio tempo e il proprio
spazio
ecco questo è ciò che ho imparato nel
mio giro antropologico sotto casa
veramente sotto casa via ghedini e l'ho
visto succedere e l'ho vissuto e l'ho
anche scritto perché altri potessero
riprodurlo in altri luoghi e con altre
persone e la bellezza che ho vissuto in
città nella marginalità della mia città
continua viverlo e sperimentando anche
in altri contesti come quello di
montagna
io sono anche un antropologo alpina
ebbene in montagna sembra più facile
riconoscere la bellezza perché la natura
una forza straordinaria una grande
energia terapeutica
eppure anche la montagna ha bisogno
delle cure dell'uomo come l'uomo ha
bisogno della montagna anche il rapporto
tra uomo e montagna che si è affinato
per secoli proprio come il rapporto dei
kayapò con la loro foresta è stato messo
a rischio e ora va ripristinato bisogna
prenderci di nuovo cura gli uni degli
altri
ed è proprio per rispondere al desiderio
soprattutto di giovani giovani
universitari che volevano tornare a
vivere
a lavorare in montagna in borghi
spopolati oppure la richiesta di
comunità che volevano progettare insieme
ai proprio futuro che è nato un gruppo
di ricerca azione l'abbiamo chiamato
montagna in movimento
anche in questo caso camminare insieme
come danzare insieme per i kayapo come
fare insieme per costruire bellezza ha
costruito legami alimentato aspirazioni
ha ridotto le distanze e le differenze
anche generazionali
anche qui ho imparato che soltanto
facendo insieme
strada facendo insieme si costruisce
bellezza la si mantiene e la si
condivide ecco questo è il tipo di
bellezza che tu nutre il mio lavoro ma
anche la mia vita perché sapere di non
essere sola e avere la certezza che dove
in un arrivo io con le mie forze con le
mie capacità c'è qualcun altro che può
farlo con me è una grande ricchezza e un
grande conforto
grazie
[Musica]